parlant des rallys avait complètement
explosé on a vu justement 1 30% en
augmentation à peu près dans les ventes
de sans alcool et demandes sont grandes
centres mais aussi la production est
grande semble les boutiques tueuse
tiennent une trentaine de bières de
microbrasseries sans alcool trèfle noir
en abitibi rouyn noranda
c'est les maires à bière sans alcool que
j'ai vu des brasseurs bien établis comme
boréale ont rajouté une offre de
produits sans alcool à leur gamme
d'autres ne produisent même que des
bières non alcoolisées comme bsa par
exemple on s'attend maintenant une
nouveauté par deux semaines une semaine
c'est vraiment intéressant on on entre
et on n'en tient pas beaucoup on en
vient de beaucoup plus sur le marché
québécois actuellement selon elle le
créneau pour occuper 10 à 15 % du marché
total de la microbrasserie d'ici
quelques années
vous entendrez l'explosion le les 30% de
cette année est vraiment juste une prime
de ce qui va se passer
nous on a l'intention de tenir un frigo
complet de bière sans alcool seulement
québécoise et nos coûts car seulement
non consentant qu'il va y avoir une
bonne offre
il faut dire que les consommateurs ne
sont plus seulement les femmes enceintes
ou les gens qui prennent des médicaments
de nombreux amateurs veulent simplement
diminuer leur consommation d'alcool des
gens vont peut-être vouloir mettre en
forme les phares attention ce qui marche
ce qu'ils boivent la légalisation du
cannabis a aussi joué un rôle
les ventes au détail et dépasse à peine
3 milliards au canada
mais quand même il ya une croissance de
25 4% par année
man et de boire de l'alcool et de
consommer du cannabis
ça va pas bien ça les gens font au choix
le pops un bock sur la rue saint denis a
lancé la marque bazar en novembre
dernier en plein coeur de la deuxième
vague en environ une dizaine de sortes
on va en avoir une quinzaine de sorties
ci en a seulement quelques zones pauvres
hères fable à dire sans alcool c'était
la planche de salut du symbole la
microbrasserie environ 415 par mois de
ses produits non-alcoolisées s'est fait
parce qu'on est petit mais on fournit
pas donc ont produit le plus de choses
possibles et puis chaque fois que ces
prêts cds au parti d'un camion et puis à
quelques jours quelques semaines
toutes nos caisses de bière sont déjà
écoulés dans les 150 points de base en
utilise d'une mesure spéciale qui
empêche le sucre de se transformer en
alcool une procédure plutôt complexes
utilisées surtout par les petites
microbrasserie phare de la bière c'est
un art fa radars sans alcool c'est
doublement en or demande aime bien
fermenté de ne pas faire d'alcool c'est
difficile les marques à grand volume
sous traite plutôt leur production en
ontario où les usines brasse leur bière
normalement puis la d alcoolisme
uniquement martin guimond lui de
continuer d'utiliser le procédé plus
artisanal mais il rêve déjà de déménager
la production dans un plus grand espace
pour profiter pleinement la tendance ici
marie claude morin radio-canada mouret